I think we talked about you here on the
news once but you and your husband
having um side by-side toilets yes yeah
that's so that's real that's real oh my
go the best part about my house I love
it thanks for one person clapping yeah I
know we fascinated by this are there any
you have also custom install that yes
see that the designer in me also wants
to know like how does it work is it how
dare you yeah I well not how dare you
there was like a bedet it was like a new
house we so there was Plumbing there was
doing construction anyways and I had an
extra toilet and I was like sir plumber
pop it pop it in you know and he was
like and I was like pop it in so it's
just the how do I ask question I don't
like being alone I'm codependent is it
just is it just the one number that you
do a side by side with is that yes okay
cuz he's violent you know well you guys
were wondering that too right you wanted
to know does he does he stand while you
sit and then you talk to each other or
he's a sitter he's a sitter he's smart